bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
l'émission les petits bricoleurs
aujourd'hui je vais vous montrer comment
réaliser un instrument de musique dont
un maracas à partir d'un rouleau de
papier de toilette vous montrer deux
formes différentes
alors pour cela nous avons besoin d'un
rouleau de papier de toilette
d'un morceau de carton une paire de
ciseaux
au crayon à papier
quelques pinces à linge
au pinceau et de la colle
des graines de lentilles
jeu du parti décopatch et paktika ni
voilà donc on va boucher les deux rôles
on va faire d'euros
avec le carton
monpoint crayon papier au couteau
donc on va découper
donc
donc après doit mettre de la colle ou de
suez va coller comme ça
la con
alors donc un an de remettre la partie
on va mettre quelques grains de
lentilles
on a 1000 entière l'intérieur donc on va
refermer donc on met de la colle
on est un petit peu
alors donc une fois c'est fait on va
passer à l'acte et à la dîme à la
décoration moi j'ai choisi du paquet
décopatch
doit prendre la mesure il est coupé
c'est
montceau mettre de la colle
la call girl dur de le papou
beaucoup comme partout
on se prend dans notre papier demeure
les remplacer
promise de lacombe
et la preuve c'est pareil
voilà donc vous laissez sécher un quart
d'heure vingt minutes et voilà maracas
été remis
alors donc on va faire l'autre maracas
en forme de berlingots alors donc
toujours d'après un rouleau de papier de
toilette alors on va écraser ce bord là
comme ça
et on écrase notre bord mais dans
l'autre sens dans le sens contraire
comme ça ça fait ça
donc on va mettre de la colle
dans l'erreur
benjamines 1 seul pour que ça sonne bien
vos prêts même principe et avant de
recoller l'autre côté on va toujours
mettre des lentilles
voilà donc une fois c'est fait et avec
des lentilles à l'intérieur ça donne
faim maintenant on va passer à la
décoration alors donc moi j'ai choisi un
papier cadeau je vais couper en
plusieurs morceaux
donc on va mettre de la colle
e
je
voilà notre maracas dernier gauche hurle
et voilà ce que ça donne
alors l'émission étant terminée j'espère
que ça vous a plu j'espère que vous
allez réaliser et vous amuser avec vos
petits et moi je vous dis à bientôt et à
la prochaine émission